no guest today it's just us three how
are you doing
all praise to the most high
i'm glad to make it another day but
before we go too into this topic you
guys see the title you guys see the
thumbnail you already know what time it
is
i quickly want to mention that it wasn't
just more than a few weeks ago when we
had sheikh uthman farooq on the podcast
and this is exactly what we talked about
check this out
this narrative and i think everyone here
can attest to it there's almost this
narrative with the muslims that we need
to be passive we need to be so peaceful
that even though we're targeted people
we're a targeted minority in a lot of
places and people come at us we need to
kind of you know lay down with our neck
on the floor ready
kind of for the chopping block and the
question is
you're saying no already masha allah uh
that's that's
i don't know i don't know i mean i i
feel what you're saying and i hear it
nowadays i don't know what book these
muslim imams are reading but that's not
the quran that's not the hadith that's
not the way of the salaf that's not the
way of rasulullah
we're not turning any other cheeks that
just this is not good
if we had become scared if we had
you know back down
not only would this person would have
done more
but i guarantee you more people like him
would have taken initiative
right
look
nowadays and i'm gonna
be a little
yeah
we see videos right of of our sisters
and others being harassed and all this
and people are like so proud of this oh
this is
where the men
oh when people think they can bully you
like i don't you all went to high school
right
when people think they can bully you and
all you're going to do is cry about it
they're going to bully you more
but the first bully that gets a black
eye
nobody's going to bully you after that
let me feel like we were talking with
him
brothers why are we awake so early
subhan allah for those of you that don't
know
angel
myself and rami we are finally in more
aligned time zones
so the times for now are going to be a
little earlier 11 a.m eastern standard
time 3 p.m uk time no more of the the
late nights you know
so
we're not going to spend too long we're
going to go right into it all right so
i was in turkey right
on a trip
and i get a video sent to the the group
chat by angel
i believe it was on hell if i'm not
mistaken and it was about this incident
that took place
so
i'm assuming both of you at least
watched the video so do one of you want
to kind of sum up what happened what
went on
you want to get it
all right
so um i actually had just seen it i
think a few minutes before
angel sent it but i just messaged y'all
man right away um
but allah so basically i don't know the
back story too well but sheikh uthman
was giving dawa and stuff um and at this
point and he's recording on his phone
he's in his car recording a guy yelling
at him
uh and being very aggressive and then
uh basically i i believe the guy
approached the car shechem and gets out
of his car
uh obviously some kind of
argument continues to ensue uh and then
the man actually pulls out a knife
because he's a coward and cannot fend
for himself he needs you know the poor
baby needs a weapon uh and then he stabs
sheikh of man and then he runs away
of man and then the guy with the knife
he runs away um
we have a little bit of a clip that
we're gonna put on right now take a
minute or two that we can react to but
so you're saying that from your
knowledge that the guy ran away the perp
like they never caught him
i don't know if he was caught or not but
after yeah after
you know booking me ran away
bro that is insane bro i believe that's
why sheikh would have been farooq in a
video he said don't think you got away
because if you don't get your punishment
in this dunya you're going to get into
akkado bro yeah
100 all right let's put that up then
just recording this quick video just
first and foremost tell all the brothers
and sisters out there making
love the the the the
and the
appreciation i'm not able to get back to
anybody right now it's too many messages
so i'm just going to record this as a
message alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah i'm fine by the will of
allah everything is fine we had an
incident today as i was downtown san
diego and there was a guy in a truck
that tried to yell uh any racist abusive
stuff and then they call us terrorists
they call us things but they're the ones
that initiate we go out to a park we go
out and give da'wah peacefully we just
share information about islam these
people they come out they're unable to
debate with us academically we give them
evidence from the quran from hadith from
their own scriptures and they have no
answer so what do they do they turn to
this type of abuse terrorism and
violence
so he tried to
yell abusive things i told him come and
face me but as i was driving he tried to
tell me and when i stopped at a gas
station to put gas in my car he parked
up top
i went closer to him and i told him if
you have something to say come say to my
face when i saw him come out of the car
i record it and and we have recording
and i'm gonna post it we're gonna clip
it and show you the recording i'm gonna
give you a warning he uses very foul
language so if you have children uh be
careful during that time this is not
language we as muslims would ever use
in it he tried to attack me physically
and you'll see the altercation and and
even though i punched him and he was too
cowardly to fight me like a man
he took a knife and he tried to cut me
alhamdulillah by the will of allah
his attack did nothing to me i went to
the urgent care and alhamdulillah i'm
perfectly fine there is no issue we're
not stopping anything we're continuing
our tawa we're going to continue with
what we're doing we're going to utah
this weekend continuing to call towards
allah if i'm in san diego i'm going out
to the park i don't need any security i
don't need anything else i have allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and allah will
protect us
this person he's not going to get away
with it
[Music]
bro you're a [ __ ] terrorist i got you
want to [ __ ] that [ __ ] you and your
muslim [ __ ] [ __ ] dog you want to
[ __ ] yourself
what's up [ __ ]
you know you think i'm scared of you
this person is going to get caught if
he's watching don't think you're going
to get away with this right we we have
your face
you're not hiding enough we have your
weapon that's been given to the police
the file report has already been filed
the detectives are on the case just like
the other person who tried to attack us
at the park
you're going to get caught and know this
that you're a coward you're a coward
you're a coward you attacked me and then
you ran from me you had a weapon i
didn't why'd you run stand and fight
like a man i'm standing there like my
feet are planted in the pavement you're
running like a coward we ask allah
subhanahu ta'ala to put us on the huq
and keep us on the huq and allah will
protect us and we will use the means of
the law that is in the land because
allah should not only be against us it
should work for us why is it that when
we get called terrorists why is it that
they don't get called for terrorists why
is it that when this happens david would
apis where are your videos now
condemning this action
when when somebody does this at hyde
park to a non-muslim you guys make
videos in a second but muslim blood
doesn't matter to you your your
hypocrisy is going to be shown where are
the news channels and nobody wants to
discuss this why because there's a
double standard but we're not going to
accept it my brothers and sisters in the
world alhamdulillah they are with me
allah is with me we will continue our
dawa in allah
name nothing can harm us on the earth or
in this in the skies and he sees and
hears everything he knows everything he
is the all-knowing he's sameer he hears
everything he's
knows everything
with this dua when we say this in the
morning allah protect us i say this dua
i'm not afraid of anybody
first thing i wanted to say for anyone
that still made it this far because
everyone has short attention spans make
dua please for shaykh with monument
we
we're not a guest feature driven podcast
we do
like to keep everything you know organic
and home based just the three of us but
we have had a few guests along the way
in the last few months alhamdulillah and
sheikh with mandeben farooq has been one
of the guests that we've we've had
multiple times i would say
he is
up there and you know the amount the
frequency that we've had him that we've
hosted him
and i can say for myself and definitely
for the other brothers that
it's been nothing but positive energy
and just a loving vibe from him every
time we have him on there's no issues
he's always on time
i say this and i hate to say this but
sometimes he even shows up before us
he's always punctual he's always
presentable and usually he's from work
you know he's in his work where he works
like a normal nine-to-five job he's not
living you know a chill life by any
means he's not taking money from the
masjid he's working and he's in a
working class and he's he's doing what
he can to you know push the needle
forward for islam he always shows up he
always makes time for us he's always he
has other than you know
just a man you know what i mean there's
not much else to say
and it really saddens me that even those
that are at the level that shaykh with
manipulating
allah
can get attacked like this bro
yes
actually i think i think he puts his
money into the dawah i don't think he
makes money from i think he puts his
money into him allah bless him
a lot and it's it's it's sad but the
higher up you get
the more subject you are to things like
this happening and i think it's
unfortunate but i think that's how you
know you're doing something right
prophet
sahaba they face the same exact
persecution
and it's very beautiful to see that he
has that same type of resilience allah
will protect me i'm going to do what i
got to do
you know you can try where you're gonna
try but you know you have to go through
allah and even if they you know succeed
in what they want to do
they never really succeed you know the
deen of allah it will prevail and
uh there's a beautiful eye in the quran
you know and this was said in regards to
the prophet
i want you all to really think about
this
because it just popped in my mind
allah spent
actually before that in the battle of
ahad
there was a word going around that the
prophet
sallam passed away
and died in battle
and the sahabas some of them started
kind of freaking out during the battle
during the during the fight
and uh they basically got uh i think
it's called being pincered but they got
pinched from two different sides
um and then
basically everyone thought the prophet
as saws passed away and people started
freaking out and then uh musab ibn
numero
he he took he took the banner of islam
the flag and he jumped on a horse and he
started writing
and and he started saying muhammad saw
is but a man he's a messenger messengers
before him have passed away
and then he he yells and asks if he were
to die or be killed in battle would you
turn back on your heels
and then allah put the same words or at
least very similar words in the quran
saying muhammad islam is but a messenger
if he were to die or be killed
would you then turn back on your heels
subhanallah and think about it like
we love sheikh of man may allah
and he's such a beautiful role model for
us to have in this day and age and well
i'm very happy that he we have him very
happy looking at him
but if something were to happen to him
or to any of us
not much changes islam goes on the hour
goes on and allah will bring someone
similar allah will bring someone else
maybe allah will bring someone even
better you know if i were to die
tomorrow i'm sure allah replaces me with
10 people that are 10 times better than
100 times better than me and the double
will keep going on just like that
this is all true
it it shows too like
we you know a lot of people look up
to the shake
right because of what he does and he's
probably he's a proper man he's a good
he is someone that is very good to look
up to you know as like a role model per
se
in today's time you know we already have
the best role models but
you know in today's time what we can see
personally
um
but if he were to pass away like let's
say he got he he did die from this
stabbing
you know like imagine how many people
who actually looked up to him
are going to
[Music]
number one they're gonna feel terrible
because he passed away but then number
two
they're going to almost have their iman
be shake
like shook him
however you want to say
and that's like it reminds me of shaking
there you go
it reminds me of the ayah in the quran
where allah is saying like do not think
of those who have died
for the sake of allah as uh being dead
but rather they are alive
or something along those lines that you
you know what i'm saying so it's like
um no matter what happens like we have
to like you say you know islam will
continue
everyone will be replaced with someone
even better so
people who do look up to the shake
you know or people who look at someone
else and let's say they pass away you
can't you can't see it in a bad light
you got to see it as like look this is
this is the dunya like this is it was
all
it's all going to happen this way like
we're born to die
like this is this is all a test this is
this is what it is you know
but in regards to what's going on
in regards to the [ __ ] getting stabbed
this guy's a [ __ ]
like there's no if ands or buts like i'm
i'm not even trying to like sugarcoat it
or trying to have a manners here now
this guy's a [ __ ]
you come bro you come up to someone you
start yelling acting all hard you can't
fight then you stab them and then you
run away
come on now
there's no other way to put it bro
i wanted to touch on a point you made
earlier that allah says in the quran
that every soul shall take death that's
inevitable someone asked shaykh ali
hamidah a question in one of his khutbas
and they were like how do i raise my
iman and one of the predominant advices
that he gave to the individual was
that if you have an opportunity be
around death more often and he was like
what do you mean and he was like be
around death if you go to like
palliative care you know when people are
in like their last few breaths you know
in the hospital bed or if you have
instances where someone dies or even
going to a graveyard like
being in those environments in those
scenarios
it really does reinvigorate your iman
because you you realize the finality and
the totality of this life this dunya
it's not forever the impermanence
that alone is something that should
shake us bro the second thing that you
were talking about about the guy being a
[ __ ] bro
from my experience bro anytime someone
tries to
let's say transgress initiate a fight
i would expect if anything the other
person will run bro subhanallah not the
person that that transgresses it
says
right subhanallah 100 don't forget your
mortality incidences like this should
affirm your iman and taqwa that you can
die at any time 100
so be prepared to die proudly with your
chest as a muslim
what is that is that me now is that my
my persona that my chart is on
that was an inside joke before wasn't it
yeah it was an inside joke now is it is
it like proper now like i have a card
who's a loyal t3m supporter and who's
not bro
yeah you know maybe maybe for the
patreon videos you can even change your
name to charizard bro instead of on hell
you know
should i get like a little charizard
like poster um bro that would be so nice
like a little toy
i'm just having like right here every
time let's do it bro we got about 15
minutes left on the stream because we
want to keep it nice and short but one
of the main messages that we wanted to
talk about today was what this means for
muslim men
we talked a little bit about the video
uh about it the topic in the video we
last filmed the shaykh with money link
in the description for anyone that
missed that we talked about integrity
self defense the reality of violence etc
etc but
people thought it was all theoretical
now this is literally practical we
talked about the value of self defense
and now sheikh wong got stabbed
so on her bro from your experience
why do you think there's such a lack of
ability to fight in muslim men and men
as a whole today
bro it's because they think it's not
gonna happen
listen i made a video talking about this
and
i was actually shocked
at the amount of muslims i had
commenting saying that oh
why do i need to learn how to fight
are you serious
are you serious like you really don't
you don't want to know how to defend
yourself and the people that you're with
you're all right with that you know and
and i haven't made another video a
little rant here but i made another
little snippet of that video saying
that if you're a man and you don't know
how to you know if you don't know how to
fight you know you don't know how to
defend yourself whether that be fighting
with your
your body or fighting with weapons
you're kind of useless
if a situation like this arises like
what are you going to do
you're going to be hiding behind someone
you're going to be running away you're
going to be scared you're going to be
looking to someone else to be able to
defend you
because you can't do anything in this
situation you don't know how to do
anything in this situation
so i just i found it really
surprising
that so many people were against knowing
how to defend yourself saying that
you'll never have to use it and it's
like all right let's say you never have
to use it
let's say you never have to fight
well it's better to have it not needed
than need it and not have it
right there's a this one saying where
it's like
uh it's better to be a warrior
in a garden
than a gardener at war
and then there's another thing where
it's like you can't ever truly be
peaceful if you're not capable of great
violence
because if you're not capable of great
violence then when a moment arises it's
you
not wanting to fight is not you being
peaceful it's you
basically
being a coward because you know like
damn i'm gonna get my my ass handed to
me i'm gonna get killed or something
like that if i actually do get in this
fight
so it's
it's very important for men to know how
to fight
the loves of questioning the channels of
waking up
because uh brother here writes the eddie
from the dean show made a self-defense
video i also saw a video from
muhammad hijab a few days ago maybe a
week and a half ago saying how to take
down a larger
with zahabi we filmed so many videos
with farah sahabi
rahim mccarthy we've talked another
talked about mma so many times on this
channel and his own like how like what
is it going to take for men to realize
that this isn't just theoretical anymore
we're slowly moving to a point in time
where
those that don't know how to fight will
literally be at a disadvantage in
protecting your your family and your
oath and covenant to allah
yeah bro i've been called crazy
you also invited more likes here bro
yeah
charlie's always no less i don't know
but listen i've been called crazy for
like the things that i do
to prepare myself for situations like
this even if it it might never happen
because you know we do our best to be
peaceful
to be loving
and you know to de-escalate situations
because of course like the best thing
you can do is
not fight the best thing you can do is
like de-escalate the situation but at
the end of the day like listen
sometimes there is no there is no
situation to de-escalate it just happens
you know like maybe you're a target or
something like that or maybe you you
were just a uh
a byproduct of something else that was
gonna happen
you know like maybe someone was doing
like a drive by it's like well you could
have caught on to that if you were
paying attention to certain factors now
will you always be able to catch some
things knowing you know
it's the color of allah if you're gonna
die this way you're gonna die this way
but it's to say like look there's so
much that one can do to prepare
themselves like
as a man
one of the first things you can start
doing is
learning how to use your body alright so
first off if you are fat ass and you
can't move
listen get in the gym
lose some weight
start being able to actually use your
body you know like lips if you can lift
something up good if you can lift your
own body up good um if you can run good
and from there like learn how to use
your body
for defense right so go into a martial
arts gym that's you know reputable do
one of the free classes learn
and then choose okay do i want to stay
in the gym do i not want to stay in the
gym do i want to go another gym
and then from there like learn a
striking art learning grappling art
that will give you a good
overall foundation and then on top of
that you want to start learning how to
use weapons
very easy you
you can go to actual lessons or i mean
the the weapon that you want to learn
that's like most
um usable nowadays is what a gun
or a knife
just learn learn it's the same way you
find
you find a place or you find someone who
can teach you this is how you learn you
don't learn by yourself you could but
it's gonna take a lot longer just find
someone else that knows what they're
doing have them show you the
groundwork and everything and you go
from there
and then another thing is guys need to
have situational awareness
how many dudes be walking out here and
be on their
phones or they're just
completely just aloof not even paying
attention to anything
you know like bro
when i hang out with people with family
or something like that people think i'm
aloof people think i'm not paying
attention to the conversations but it's
actually the opposite i'm paying
attention to everything around me
like i have situational awareness where
i'm like aware of like each person
that's coming
within like a 30 30 foot radius even 50
foot radius and i'm i'm paying attention
to what these people are doing what's
their threat level
and like what are their weaknesses what
kind of things they're going to use
against me or what can i use against
them i'm paying attention to all of this
so this is stuff that like as a man as a
woman too but more so the man if you're
going to be
the protector of yourself and the people
you're with like you have to
you have to be honest and again like i
may sound crazy but
it's better to have it not needed that
literally been called conspiracy
theorists how about you
uh yeah probably
it's wow
like the things we're saying it's not
it's not just out of thin air yeah the
things that angel does when he's in
social situations doesn't mean he's
socially
in that in inept is that a word socially
inept
or or he's he's socially awkward
anything he's literally sizing up the
situation and making sure everyone's
safe you'd be a good bodybuilder bro
subhanallah like if we ever do the
off-grid thing then you're definitely
going to be the bodyguard bro 100
me bro what's on your mind
i just want to mention a verse in the
quran because
i didn't know people had that kind of
response and it's very sad to see that
they do and there's a very beautiful
verse in the quran
that came up recently
in class
and where we're learning about chaos
chaos is when you take an ayah and you
can basically
use your logic because allah gives you a
reason to extend it to other things in
life
um and i won't go too in depth but this
ayah allah says
it says prepare against them what you
believers can of military power and
cavalry to deter the enemies of allah
and your enemies
and i think the ayah actually says
horses specifically
but
and later it says to threaten the
enemies your enemies and the enemies of
allah now not everyone's our enemy not
every non-muslim is our enemy but the
enemies of allah are those who are
fighting against the deen and fighting
against us inevitably people like that
they're the enemies of allah and if we
don't have to go get horses and and buy
weapons and all that stuff but even just
being intellectually prepared and
knowing how to fight is enough
to strike fear into these people's
hearts and you might say well i don't
have any enemies you know i don't you
know i don't encounter these people this
doesn't happen where i live in blah blah
land
the next part of the verse it says
it says to deter your enemies and the
enemies of allah
as well as other enemies unknown to you
but known to allah subhanallahu
he says even if you don't know them
allah knows them prepare against them
anyways and then allah says whatever you
spend in the cause of allah will be paid
to you in full and you will not be
wronged if you learn how to fight
for the sake of allah to protect
yourself and to protect your loved ones
and protect the muslims even the random
muslims you see on the street because
you're still your brother or sister or
uncle are on
if you do that and you never have to
fight a day in your life allah will
still reward you for doing it for his
sake
and you will lose nothing and you will
gain everything
because uh
as basically as angel was saying before
it's it's better to have it and not need
it
than need it and not have it and uh
basically if if you're in a situation
and you can't do anything you're not
peaceful you're just harmless
you're like a little kitten like meowing
at the they do it basically i also i
also see an immense amount bro of
weakness acceptance today in today's
society
they call it fat acceptance and this
acceptance that acceptance
if anger was here giving people you know
re affirmations and reinforcements for
being weak
you know saying it's okay to be this you
were born this way it's okay to be that
way you don't need to go to the gym you
don't need to learn how to fight i
believe he would be more socially
acceptable and more liked but the reason
that he's getting these comments is
because he's calling out people's
weaknesses and most people aren't even
aware of the weaknesses that they have
so it's going to come as a shock to them
but the ones that are they don't want to
do anything about it so they're gonna be
like who are you what gives you the
audacity to talk to me like that you
know you're just you're just a youtuber
yeah that's
that's the thing man and what's crazy
this is gonna sound real messed up
maybe it might show how crazy i am i
don't know allah
but um
we have a fight-or-flight response yeah
so something happens and our body allah
created it to either have a fight or
flight response
the more you train
the more you prepare yourself
the more of a fight response you're
gonna have
right
now of course we want to de-escalate
everything
we want to
not fight the goal is not to fight we
don't want to fight like if you can
de-escalate everything perfect
but listen
if you don't know how to fight and then
your
flight response kicks on this is like
fear this is a state of fear and this is
not a good feeling i'll be honest it's
not a good feeling
uh but here's where things take a huge
twist
right when your fight response kicks in
and you've been training not to say that
you know you're gonna win but you know
okay i know something i so i'm gonna i'm
gonna fight you i'm gonna stand my
ground
that's exhilarating bro like it feels so
good and um again like i said we
de-escalate the fight but let's say it
actually came down to it you're actually
about to
get into this altercation whether it be
with weapons whether it be
just hand-to-hand combat like
you probably won't feel more alive than
you've ever felt in your life at that
point in time
[Music]
does that make me crazy no no that i
think that's what she called men was
saying as well or something similar he
was talking about
well it was i guess along the same lines
he was saying when you're when when you
show them that you're basically firm and
you trust not allah you know allah is
your protector and you're not you're
unwavered you're ready to fight
they basically get scared of you because
you're basically you're you're well your
will is just stronger than theirs in
that fight uh your determination is
stronger than theirs and they get scared
and obviously you're gonna feel you know
like a big man after something like that
[Music]
i was just saying like the altercation
in and of itself
but yeah
yeah
yeah it i'm referring to like the
the animalistic side of us you know and
and i stuck to a lot i'm not glorifying
it
you know like again like if we only
acted out of the
our animalistic side then we'll be no
better than the animals
that's why allah gave us the intellect
but i'm telling y'all like if you
if you're trying in a fight
and unless you get into a situation you
can't de-escalate it and it's it's gonna
turn into a fight and your fight
response kicks in instead of your flight
response like you will never feel more
alive than
in that moment right there
it's like all your senses kick on you
become like superhuman it's
it's crazy to be honest
adrenaline spike
so
for a lot of the viewers that are new
and haven't seen any of our videos
regarding mma or fighting in
self-defense on her bro
you already mentioned in brief you know
join a gym if you're fat you know
be more mobile lose some weight join an
mma gym do some free classes right
what about those that are already doing
that
what advice would you have for them
those that are kind of in shape kind of
you know they know a little bit how to
fight
learn situational awareness
learn
the weak points in people's bodies
learn pressure points
on google or you can again you find
others
that know these things i personally
have had a mixture of like google and
other people that i've learned from
but it's
finding weaknesses is very easy it's
like sometimes i'll look at people and
all if i see someone who's really tall
i know that they are the center of
gravity is higher up
so meaning that if something were to
like happen i'm going straight for their
legs
you know if i see someone who's shorter
i know their center of gravity is
definitely down lower so i wouldn't even
try to take them down like i'm gonna do
stuff that's uh basically gonna chop
down at the legs not not in a way to
take them down but just to immobilize
them
you know and someone said it in a
comment it was like oh if you're a man
like learn how to kick
because like most people in the fight
they don't expect you to kick
but you should learn how to do like a
muay thai kid not like a taekwondo kick
taekwondo kick you're not gonna do much
you're probably gonna
get caught and thrown to the ground
about it bro sam writes i can't even
blow up a balloon let alone fight i
guess
it's better the devil that you know than
the devil that you don't know so if you
know that you have this weakness then
you know you got some work to do
muhammad allah guys if you made it this
far comment down below hashtag stand up
because we got to stand up to the
oppressor but not just that because you
know
there was a point in time just like he
said that uh angel used to be on the
stream standing up bro so alhamdulillah
came a long way
in the world
don't worry i'm gonna be standing up
real soon
just wait on it
all right we're going to wrap this up
two more questions brother malik writes
what do you suggest people start local
judo gyms i'm a bodybuilder but i want
to get better with combat not that i
don't have hands though
uh find the mma engine now it's only
focused on mma but mma in a sense where
they have like
maybe muay thai
boxing kickboxing
and then they have like the ground like
maybe they might have judo prison jiu
jitsu
um wrestling stuff like that
you know in my opinion muay thai and
brazilian jiu jitsu
is gonna be best
but everyone differs everyone has their
own opinion but you know
i suggest just go in there and learn
ground and striking you don't want to
learn just one because then it's going
to be incomplete you know like i said in
my video
every fight starts standing up
but
almost every fight ends up on the ground
inevitably so you got to be prepared for
both
[Music]
all right guys we're going to end off
the stream around me insha allah do your
thing and keep your eyes out guys if you
made it this far for an upload that we
do later on today 150 viewers in the
stream alhamdulillah
for everyone tuning in that should mean
at least 450 likes you already know all
right
with that being s
my